23 GOALS THE A BEFORE AND MADE
THE OLD START TEAM.
LEVY WAS THERE AND HAD GOOD SO
THIS HOCKEY GAME THE SE THE PAN
HAVING ANY TIME AT ALL, THE
PUCK WAS INSIDE ON THIS GOAL,
THREE-GAME ROAD TRIP AND NOW
HE MAKES A SAVE.
HE HAD NONO
I THINK GOING BACK YOU HAVETHE
PASSES ARE NOT ON.
THEY'RE JUST NOT ANTICIPATING
EACH OTHER AREHAARER IS BACK FO
FIVE MAN UNIT.
BUT HE ROLLS IT DOWN AND
DE
HE KNOCKS IT AWAY AND GRAYPANTH
REINHARDT.AND CHUCK DUMPS IT DO
THEY KNOW IT'S IN THE NUTS.
THEY ARE CELEBRATING.THE LINE B
TOWARDS LOW AGAIN.
>> IS ONE FOR THE OTTAWA
SENATOTO
SOME OPPORTUNITIES.
>> HERE ARE THE PANTHERS NUMBERH
ALL OF THIS DONE   AND
BATTLED THROUGH SOME COVID
ISSUES AND INJURIES
SHOT BLOCKED AGAIN.
THAT'S 22 SCORE.
CHUCK GETS A POWER PLAY GOAL.